Prof: So you remember
this slide from several lectures
ago.
What are they trying to make?
Remember what the point of this
synthesis was,
this particular reaction?
The idea was to do a catalytic
reaction with something that was
chiral as the catalyst,
to do an oxidation on sulfur,
to make a single enantiomer of
omeprazole.
And remember the idea was that
the product,
after you've gone through these
three steps that we showed you
before,
that the product then comes
back and is the catalyst again,
and you can do another cycle.
So, in fact,
there's this thing called a
catalytic cycle.
So what comes in is a peroxide
and a sulfide,
and what comes out is an
alkoxide and the product that
you want, the oxidized product;
where an oxygen has been added
to that unshared pair,
that high HOMO.
And so the idea of the chiral
oxidizing agent was so you'd get
a single enantiomer of the
product.
But do you remember what
happened?
Student:  It was racemic.
Prof: Right,
it gave racemic material.
So what did they do?
Do you remember?
Pardon me?
Student:
>.
Prof: Yeah,
ethyldiisopropylamine they
added;
these researchers added,
in 2000.
And they found out that that
gave a 94% enantiomer excess,
but for no obvious reason.
Now it would be great if we
knew what the reason for this
was.
And it turned out that,
in fact, this kind of oxidative
catalytic reaction,
to be stereospecific,
to give a single enantiomer,
was the source of the Nobel
Prize in 2001.
And if we click on this thing
here, we can see -- should see
-- yeah, there we go.
So this is the Nobel website,
and you can see that K. Barry
Sharpless here got the Nobel
Prize in 2001 for his work on
chirally catalyzed oxidation
reactions;
so exactly this reaction.
So if anyone can tell us how
ethyldiisopropylamine does its
trick, who should it be?
Barry Sharpless, right?
>
<<Technical
adjustments>>
Prof: There,
we're all set.
Prof: Thanks Mike.
Well I'd do anything for my
friend Mike, because he saved me
from publishing errors in JACS
at least once.
And he's saved a lot of us,
who were willing to listen to
him,
because he's got a genius for
seeing flaws in the beautiful
stories that people tell,
and then they realize that
their beautiful stories are
going to be too slick,
usually;
and Nature doesn't like things
to be too slick.
Well I'm going to just use -- I
think the next slide should be
--
<<Technical
adjustments>>
Prof: Well this is
something which we all possibly
manipulate in-utero.
It's interesting,
because many things in our
body,
like a part can be on the left
or right,
and a mirror image -- I assume
that means they're mirror-image
related then.
But this is a vein and two
arteries that has a sheath on
it, and it's the umbilical cord
of a mammal.
And it's got a nice screw axis;
you know how we like to pull
our hand down a screw axis.
And then I have other reasons
why I think I handled it.
And then they take it away from
you at birth;
they cut it and they take it
away.
It becomes a narcissistically
cathected object.
And that means you're in
trouble because you can't ever
heal that wound.
You want to get it back,
but you can't heal it.
You needed that mirror,
that umbilical cord,
back there when you were born.
Anyway, that's why I went crazy
trying to do asymmetric
synthesis.
And now, if you're a chemist,
unless you're in deep space --
I don't know if they have any
carbon atoms out there,
but you got to be in a very
high vacuum to get them.
But this is the way we make
organic compounds,
right?
But we don't really do it this
way because we have to live on a
condensed phase of the earth.
So these are two -- but you put
them together.
This is a point.
Then you get a line.
It's polyacetylene really.
But let me -- give me poetic
license of just having it be a
line.
And I'll take one unit out,
and now if I add things across
that line, I get into the plane,
A and B, or I can add them
cis or trans.
And essentially you can make
anything this way,
almost, if you could do it by
just surgically adding things.
Now we're in the plane.
And now the job in the plane --
and I've actually drawn a
trans-disubstituted
2-butene.
And it has a shape like this,
right?
It has a methyl group here,
a methyl group here,
and then hydrogens.
So there's open space in these
quadrants.
And if you look at me coming at
you this way,
and if I turn around,
you see it's going to be --
well you'll see it's going to
be a mirror image situation.
But I'm flat.
So I have no chirality,
as a starting point.
I'm in the plane of flat.
So then if I add hydrogen to
it, I get nothing interesting.
But if I add an atom,
like oxygen,
to it, like here,
then I've pyramidalized it.
And so I can either add the
oxygen from my front,
and go like that -- epoxide.
Or I can add it from my back,
and I go like that.
And that's the other
mirror-image compound.
That's a really cool way.
And it works.
You can make epoxides that way.
And we have reagents today
where you can recognize the
front and the back of a flat
object, that has pro-chirality,
like this.
And back in the early,
in the mid -- early seventies,
we saw this industrial reaction
that was nice.
You could take vanadium and
molybdenum,
and you could epoxidize olefins
with these things called --
well I don't have the darn
structure unfortunately --
but it's
t-butylhydroperoxide.
It's the alcohol group here,
with a peroxide bond.
And I think you've already
learned that peroxide bonds are
weak bonds.
They have a low lying
Ïƒ* orbital,
and you can attack them on the
back side and transfer atoms to
make transfer to carbons,
like a HOMO of an olefin.
So what we noticed -- I noticed
in one case that allylic
alcohols were very much --
seemed to be special.
It was just noticed by English
chemists in the thirties that
they seemed to react better than
just normal alcohols.
And so, but nobody had taken
any really -- action on that.
Prof: We're not as fast
as some people at getting to
this stuff.
So we should say that an
allylic alcohol group is one
that has an oxygen on the carbon
next to the double bond.
Prof: Oh, oh yeah.
Prof: The OH is --
Prof: Oh right. I forget.
The allylic alcohol -- allylic
means -- allylic,
you're alpha,
one atom away from an olefin.
So you could have anything
there;
nitrogen and oxygen.
So you could have an OH,
like in ethanol;
that's an allylic alcohol.
This is an allylic alcohol
right -- where is it?
I don't -- see,
I'm sorry, I don't have the
right structures.
This is the allylic alcohol.
It would be, if I go back one;
I'll show you,
not by going forward.
Prof: There's the
allylic alcohol actually.
Prof: Yeah,
but I got one -- like here,
this is a carbon,
that's a carbon,
that's a carbon.
By putting an OH group there,
that's allylic alcohol.
If I have another carbon,
it's homoallylic.
But it has a handle now,
and that handle allows it to
grab hold of the vanadium.
The vanadium has all these
alcohol -- these are esters.
Imagine that's phosphorous.
It is like phosphorous actually.
But it's a yellowish liquid,
and it exchanges its ligands
like the wind,
with alcohols.
So they come in, they go out.
It's a real dance.
It's fast.
You don't have to worry about
that happening.
Phosphates, we'd all be dead if
that happened;
we'd melt.
But this is a transition metal.
It goes to here.
Now, and when I'm the metal,
and I have oxygen here,
and then I say have an arm.
You can imagine my arm being a
double bond, with Ï€
going like this.
And here, on my belly,
I'm going to have an atom --
and this is an atom like -- it
should be red.
Oxygen's red.
But he knows why. I don't.
Except for blood.
So you come like this and you
grab it, and it pops off me --
I'm the activated thing on the
metal -- and it goes on to
there.
That's an epoxide;
a three-membered ring.
And if I attack it with a
backhand, I would get the
opposite result,
in terms of attack.
And that doesn't happen,
because the geometry of the
transition states and the
projections of the center --
you can't get as close to a
center shot on this thing,
with a backhand.
So that's my way of starting to
explain.
We're going to explain a little
bit more.
Mike's going to do some acting
later, and you'll see it a
little bit more clearly -- the
topology of this situation.
But here it's cool because you
get this template.
It's like a mandrel.
You grab hold of this oxygen
atom, which is proto-oxygen.
The metal has lots of empty
orbitals.
It's a d^0 metal.
It activates the thing this
way, and then the olefin
lone-pair, the HOMO,
attacks the backside,
and all this funny business
goes on.
But there's no mechanism.
It's a no-mechanism transfer.
It's one of these -- like you
draw a bunch of arrows and
everything happens sort of in a
smooth way;
no ions involved,
unlike SN_2 chemistry.
Okay, slow step is then this
step.
And then it comes off and more
stuff goes on and it goes
around.
So that's the trick we played
here.
The first idea was take
advantage of fixing the thing.
So once you've fixed this flat
system that you want to make go
pop up this way,
or that way,
now you have a chance of doing
it,
because the thing you're
transferring from can recognize
this kind of situation,
from that one,
by -- it's part of the same
molecule temporarily.
In fact, it's a covalent bond,
right there,
at this point.
Too much, I always say too much.
Okay, let's keep going.
Then came a great man from
Japan.
He's now a head professor at
Kyoto, Oshima.
He was a fantastic boiler room
producer in titanium,
osmium;
you name it.
I think that was where all the
work was done for the Nobel
Prize;
it was done at MIT.
But it happened at Stanford;
just because I was there for a
few years.
But you know those early years
in your career,
when you do your work in the
boiler room, are what produce
you.
Like your personality doesn't
change after you're four years
old -- right?
-- or three years old;
you're pretty much locked in,
unfortunately,
in some ways.
This is vanadium system,
and we put on this chiral
machinery here,
and it gave us 80% ee;
that means enantiomeric excess
was -- it was 90% one isomer --
enantiomer, the right hand say,
and 10% the other.
And this looks good.
But it only works for that one
substrate, and all the other
types with it -- you can have
like methyls there,
or a methyl there,
and you get nothing.
So you have to get everything
customized.
This ligand,
you got to get the right
ligand, the -- and that's what
you expect with Nature.
We're taught by Emil Fisher --
the lock and key.
Nature is supposed to be very,
very touchy about changing her
preferences.
And that was what we expected.
Well I didn't expect that.
I expected that this type of
olefin and this type,
with something,
that all these would need a
class of catalysts.
There are about six shapes of
olefins.
So that's what my dream was,
to get maybe six catalysts.
Because we didn't have the
paraphernalia that nature has
all around.
Well for years we tried.
Ten years we didn't get
anything.
It was always this game of like
almost no reliability.
And then when we came to
titanium -- we'd been working
with vanadium and molybdenum.
We came over to titanium,
and we put in tartaric acid
ester one day.
This wasn't me, it was Katsuki.
He should've gotten the Nobel
Prize with me,
because this means half of this
-- I picked the right metal,
at that time,
and the right system,
but he's the one who picked the
right ligand.
And let's go on to the next
thing.
You'll see, this is tartaric
acid.
This is so-called natural.
It comes from grapes.
It's the cream of tartar.
When you protonate it,
it becomes tartaric acid.
Over here is the unnatural.
But there's a plant in Africa,
Bauhinia reticulata,
that has about -- it's a huge
area, around the Sahara.
So there's maybe more of that
so-called unnatural than there
is of the natural.
You know the story about
tartaric acid.
And it goes way back to Louis
Pasteur, with the discovery of
tetrahedral carbon;
I mean then the precursor to it.
Grapes, very sexy looking
things.
We always like -- humans seem
to like to drink them,
and eat them,
and look at them.
This is the famous recipe.
So that day,
Katsuki took a tartrate and put
it together with -- oh I think I
forgot to say something here.
Yeah, just quickly.
Maybe I don't have it.
No, it comes later. Okay.
TBHP was the kind of oxygen
we'd always been using.
There's the titanium,
which comes from titanium
dioxide or titanium
tetrachloride.
Everything that's white in this
world, all these -- that's
titanium dioxide.
It's the only white pigment
anybody ever uses.
And so that's titanium dioxide.
It's very insoluble.
But you can make it into this
soluble derivative,
if you do the right chemistry.
And this is the wine acid.
We put in diisopropyl tartrate
as an ester,
and we kept getting 90%,
100%, 95 --
every olefin we put in that was
an allylic alcohol,
that had this handle on it,
gave Katsuki --
about a week of this,
and we were just about dying.
I was looking at him;
he was looking at me.
We didn't believe it, you know.
So we had to try to kill this.
But it was right.
And so it meant that here we
had some new principle.
We could actually just take one
catalyst and get them all;
almost get them all.
But they had to be allylic
alcohols.
So this is the famous recipe
discovered I think on an October
day in 1980 at Stanford.
I'd already decided to go back
to MIT.
I might not have decided to do
that, if this had happened
sooner.
We get depressed when our
research isn't working;
I mean, whether we don't show
it or not.
It's the only thing that
matters really to a real killer
research guy who wants to
understand what makes nature
tick.
And whatever else -- if that's
going well, life is good.
Otherwise nothing's good.
So I went back to MIT,
which I wouldn't have if I'd
gotten this about three months
earlier, probably.
And here we are.
There's Katsuki-san drinking
tartaric aqueous -- it's about
5% aqueous tartaric acid -- in
wine and champagne.
And this was on the porch at
the Mudd Building,
which was where our lab was,
on the top.
And what I'm going to show here
is why Katsuki was so important,
in a nutshell.
This is really a nice little
substrate.
It has this type of alcohol;
it's trisubstituted.
But you see the OH here?
There's no OH over here.
This is a more reactive olefin
for the transfer of the oxygen,
but it doesn't have the handle.
So this one ends up winning by
a factor of 200,
in this system where the
epoxidation requires the thing
to bind and go in
intramolecularly.
And that's nice in its own
right, but to get -- we got
racemate all the time,
of course, because we have no
face selection.
And titanium goes about ten
times faster with tartrate.
When you add it,
this does something to make --
every other metal,
years before Oshima had taken
vanadium and molybdenum,
which were the best for
isolated double bonds.
But you put tartrate in,
it kills them.
So my instinct would not have
been to put tartrate in again.
This is the kind of thing --
everything in science,
the rules change all the time.
You wake up in the morning --
you should iterate your favorite
desire every morning.
It's going to look different to
you in the shower.
And you can never -- the atomic
bomb was made by theoretical
geniuses.
But the guys who did it,
actually they had aluminum foil
on the source,
and they kept it on there for
about a year or two.
Some guy said,
"No, I don't think we need
this.
What about if we take it
off?"
That was the answer.
I mean, these guys are like us.
They just try this,
try that, in the lab.
Right?
That's what gets really things
done in this world.
The theories are important.
Nobody would even think about
trying it without the theory.
But -- okay,
"A man in California just
won a Nobel Prize for mixing
paint and wine!"
That's what they said,
in the LA Times.
It's sort of true.
Titanium dioxide and tartaric
acid.
And there's the -- I like my
students to know where Mother
Earth is.
And I like things to be cheap.
I don't like to be far away
from a river that's strong,
or a power source;
or in this case,
this is tartaric acid.
It comes in 100-pound bags.
This is Spanish tartar,
and this is Victor Martin,
who's one of the heroes of this
chemistry, from the Canary
Islands.
This comes to Pfizer.
They make things out of it.
But it comes in ships in
100-pound bags.
And we still have that in our
stockroom somewhere.
There's my daughter celebrating
the synthesis of the unnatural
sugars >
by this method.
And oh I got the wrong one,
didn't I?
I threw out the wrong -- yeah,
anyway, you're going to have to
interpret.
This is the mirror-image of the
picture that was taken,
I guess;
because you see the name over
here is backwards.
But she's looking at the
l-sugars.
These are the ones we don't
make.
There's eight of those,
the hexoses.
And these are the ones Emil
Fisher made, in his famous work;
about the best chemist who ever
lived,
except for van't Hoff,
who was even better,
because he did organic
stereochemistry and physical
chemistry,
and I think he was the greatest
chemist who ever lived;
van't Hoff was.
But anyway, Fisher was better
than anybody who lived in this
century, in terms of
understanding and arguments and
rationale of synthesis.
And he made a lot of these
sugars over here.
But this is Tito Simboli.
She's a photographer,
my wife's friend.
This is taken in 1983.
It was on the cover of
Chemistry in Britain.
And Hannah was seven.
And anyway, Tito was a friend.
So she took the picture.
And this book though,
is a huge book,
which was gotten by Nancy
Schrock, who's in charge of the
MIT Archives and is a book
restorer.
And Nancy -- so here we got
Nancy Schrock,
we got Tito Simboli,
whose husband is Dan McFadden;
won the Nobel Prize in
economics ten years later,
and Dick won the Nobel Prize a
couple of years ago,
and I won it in 2001.
So the picture is kind of
connected.
And there's Lewis Carroll,
of course, looking-glass milk.
And Emil Fisher.
It's a heavy duty picture;
for me anyway.
>
There's Nexium,
and maybe we're getting -- I
went too far into the other
stuff.
But here's the atom,
the red atom,
that's going to end up being
transferred onto the sulfur.
And well Mike showed -- told
you that the diisopropylamine --
what would its role be?
I hope I can go to the board
now and show you a few things.
But this catalyst is exactly
the recipe.
And it makes billions of
dollars a year,
this product.
Right?
But the patent is -- the
Stanford patent is no longer
valid.
It's run out;
even though it hadn't run out
when they started.
But they didn't believe that it
might.
This was an infringing of that
patent actually in the
beginning.
But nobody in universities sues
companies.
They can't afford to.
Stanford couldn't afford to.
Prof: Do you want to go
to the board now?
Prof: Should I? Yeah.
<<Technical
adjustments>>
Prof: Do you remember
the vanadium picture?
I'll make it titanium now.
But there's this alcohol group
and --
<<Technical
adjustments>>
Prof: And on this we
have this peroxide group that's
bound, and it's bound datively
there.
It's got this tertiary-butyl
group here.
And then the alcohol is bound
here, and well it goes sort of
down.
I'll just try to show some of
the stereochemistry.
And then underneath it's coming
-- yeah, it's coming folded like
this, underneath.
I can't draw very well,
but this is supposed to be
coming with its lone pairs,
it's Ï€ bonds,
on the backside of this bond.
So we're going to do an attack
on there, and we'll break this
bond, we'll bring the lone pair
here in, and we get the epoxide.
Now, but the thing about this
is patent lawyers can be very
creative --
like every field has creative
people,
and Yale is connected to this
fellow,
Bert Rowland.
And he was in Palo Alto at the
time, at a company,
and he had just gotten famous,
or almost infamous,
because that patent was really
aggressive;
this Boyer-Cohen Patent.
He wrote the Boyer-Cohen Patent.
He's related to Mike,
because he got his Ph.D.
with Bartlett at Harvard,
like Mike did.
So that's a long time ago.
That's a great-something
relationship.
And then comes Wiberg,
who's here at Yale.
He was at Seattle then,
and he took a post-doc.
He decided he liked chemistry
in principle.
He was smart;
a physical-organic chemist.
But he didn't like the lab;
he wasn't any good in the lab
and he didn't like to be there.
So he became a patent attorney,
and did very well.
And he writes great patents.
And so he read our paper,
our first paper.
We gave him the little
communication.
And then he got Katsuki and me
over to his office,
and he interviewed us for about
ten minutes.
The next day we got a patent.
He never changed a word of it.
And I'll tell you why it's
creative, I think.
We're getting ready for the
Nexium.
But I could tell you about that.
If we don't make it,
it won't matter that much.
But here's the main -- so this
is going to be the oxygen;
and they should be red but we
have pink here.
So does this one.
But that one doesn't transfer.
This is the one that transfers.
So what Rowland said is you got
a metal, which can grab things.
Now the things it grabs,
it could be X,
it could be sulfur,
or an amine group that it could
grab.
And then he just drew -- I
think he drew a carbon with no
-- it could be any carbon.
It didn't have to have to have
just CH_2.
And then he drew this, G.
And then he drew -- yeah,
he did draw an oxygen atom
here, I guess,
but it was activated.
And so this oxygen,
he didn't have a generality
there.
That was specific.
That was the only thing that
was specific,
these two things.
So this could be any kind of
lone pair.
An olefin is a lone pair.
Sulfur has a lone pair.
Phosphorous has a lone pair.
Nitrogen has a lone pair.
And sure enough,
when I read that,
I said, "My God,
this gives us ideas."
So we started doing amino
alcohols.
All these things work.
You know?
So this is from Bert Rowland,
the patent attorney.
He was a co-inventor of those
other reactions.
We never wrote any more patents.
It's a good thing.
Don't waste your time on
patents.
They'll just not use them until
they expire.
And we never -- we made enough
to go on a vacation once a year,
in a car, not too far away.
>
Katsuki and I,
we got -- people think we got
rich.
We got the most -- one year we
got $20,000 each,
or something.
That was a really sharp
maximum, from the bag-a-bug
gypsy moth traps –
Disparlure.
But okay, to show the transfer,
I think maybe it would be nice
for us, Mike and I,
to show what features have to
be over here in these ligands.
You see, the tartrate has this
feature.
It grabs the titanium,
like out front.
Let's kind of put it out front
here.
So the titanium is out here.
And down in the back here you
have this ester group,
and up in the back,
over here, you have an ester
group.
And I can't remember if that's
what we planned to do.
But out here,
on the front,
it's coming -- the alcohol --
this G-group,
and there's an oxygen that's
hot over here,
that can be transferred.
So Mike's going to put that --
I'm going to put that on and --
Prof: I'm the olefin.
Prof: Yeah,
you're the -- is that okay if
you're the ole--
Prof: It's okay.
Prof: Maybe it's better
if I'm the olefin.
>
Prof: No,
okay.
I'll be the titanium.
Prof: Yeah,
you're the titanium.
Prof: So see,
I've got this oxygen that wants
to go off, because it's a weak
bond.
And I've got to get it over to
him.
He's the allylic alcohol.
But we're going to pretend he
doesn't have to bind to me.
We're just going to do this
straight-out attack here.
And yeah, it's like that. Right?
So I'm blocked here,
but I'm open in these
quadrants.
Prof: So you're natural
tartaric acid.
Prof: Is that right?
Boy you're quick.
I don't -- okay,
so I'm natural?
>
Prof: Okay,
well wait a minute.
And also, but I'm not like
this, I'm like that.
You see, I'm in a
three-dimensional world,
because I'm tartaric acid.
So I'm sticking out here.
So I'm a chiral object now.
My mirror-image won't
superimpose.
But he's, yeah he's that way.
He's a trans-olefin.
>
And he looks like an Egyptian,
like -- anyway.
Prof: I have a double
bond here, right?
Prof: Yeah.
Prof: The question is
whether you're going to come on
here or on my back.
Prof: Actually the
double -- we don't have this
quite right.
Can you get an arm down here?
Because the double bonds is
here.
Prof: No,
no, the double bond is going
this way.
Prof: Okay.
You've got it going that way.
Prof: So here, right now.
Prof: Okay,
so yeah double bond's going
that way.
Okay.
Prof: Thank you.
So you --
Prof: Yeah, that's good.
Prof: Get your tartrate
on.
Prof: Okay,
because I could go like -- I
may not -- it's like this,
I'm sorry.
Yeah, I got to go like that.
I could go like that.
That's the mirror-image.
Okay, now I'm coming towards
him.
Prof: But I want to go
on my back.
Prof: Okay,
you want it on your back?
Oh my gosh.
Oh I can't do it. See?
But that's the other -- you
need the other mirror-image for
that one.
So I come this way,
and I can -- it says
"Think Safety".
Oh.
So now you have to -- yeah,
if he was a good yoga person,
he could pyramidalize it a
little better.
>
Yet now when you put him that
way, he's one enantiomer,
and if you put him on the other
way, that's the other
enantiomer.
Simple.
It's real simple, isn't it?
Thanks Mike.
Yeah, we just organized that
ten seconds before we came over,
as you can see.
We didn't have any red ping
pong balls.
It's good with Velcro.
You can do it with Velcro.
We did it once with Velcro red
balls.
Okay now.
Prof: Back to the screen.
Prof: Yeah,
I think we're -- oh no,
I'm not back to the screen.
Let's leave it alone.
This is going to be a little --
<<Technical
adjustments>>
Prof: Now if you look at
the structure of the omeprazole.
I won't put all the bells and
whistles on it.
It's an imidazole structure,
benzimidazole,
which has a benzene ring,
two nitrogens.
It's a five-membered aromatic
heterocycle.
And so you have a double bond
and one H.
And I can't remember what's on
the sulfur.
Is it an aromatic ring,
or is it a benzyl?
It's an aromatic benzyl thing,
I think.
And you might look at this and
say, "This doesn't look
anything like Bert Rowland's
thing there."
Because where are the anchor
points that we need,
the group that binds the metal?
We have the lone pairs all
right;
you know, two lone pairs,
rabbit ears.
And there, if you put oxygen on
one side, it's the same story as
before.
This isn't flat to start with.
But now we have these pairs.
If you put something here,
you get one enantiomer.
You put something there,
you get the other.
So the idea was to try to get
-- and Kagan had done this.
He's a fellow that could've won
the Nobel Prize,
I thought should of.
But he's in France.
And he had done a lot of great
work in asymmetric chemistry.
And he took the titanium
tartrate catalyst of Katsuki,
and he found if you put a
little water in it,
and you did the right things,
and wished --
it wasn't as general,
but he got very good asymmetric
addition.
So titanium was already known
to do this.
But the feature that's
important here is the pKa of
this benzimidazole is probably
-- I looked it up;
I think it's below that of an
alcohol.
So that means it can go on the
titanium, reversibly.
So you see the titanium has
alcohols on it,
or ligands like this,
or -- and this can exchange.
So we can have that come off,
and this N go on,
for this heterocycle,
and the benzene ring's down
here.
And now we have something like
that, a covalent bond.
And we've got the sulfur here,
and we also have the alcohol.
So there's an equilibrium where
you could invoke that.
But this is not as easy to
probably do as an alcohol.
It's more encumbered,
and it's probably -- kinetics
are slower for this,
and off of oxygen,
for the hydrogen transfers that
are needed.
So I hypothesize here that what
the diisopropyl -- what the
Hünig's base,
we call it
diisopropylethylamine is doing.
This is such a hindered amine
that it can't react with
anything, but it's good for
getting protons.
So it can't itself get at the
oxygen;
which you would worry about.
It would make an N-oxide.
And it can't bind to the
titanium anyway.
Titanium hates nitrogen.
If you have an oxygen around,
it'll spit it out so fast it'll
make your head spin.
I mean, this thing is amazing
hating nitrogen -- titanium,
and silicon too,
but especially titanium.
So it's never going to get
involved with titanium.
So what's it going to do?
Well remember when you try to
get chemistry going in a system
like this, this amine has enough
pKa power to pull this proton.
And usually you could write a
concerted mechanism.
Like let me erase some of this
and have some room here.
Well I shouldn't erase that.
I'll go over here.
You got this benzimidazole,
with a sulfur here,
and I'm going to put the
hydrogen up here.
Whenever you engage compounds
in reaction, acid-base
reactions, you look for the
basic sites and the acidic
sites.
There's the acidic site.
You might think that's where
the titanium goes.
But usually the mechanism for
these reactions involves a
simultaneous loss of this
proton, and attack here.
This is the place you can
attack.
So you'll be attacking the
titanium here,
and you're going to get some
help from --
you're going to get a lot of
help from this amine,
because you can put it
someplace;
just take it right off.
But you'll have some of that
ammonium salt around too,
a little bit,
transiently.
And this will help you,
because you need to move things
around.
That's why this reaction was
not good without that amine.
You need to scramble the system
and keep it rolling,
so that the things get on and
off.
Catalysis often has this --
like there's six,
maybe.
There's always a loop,
and if you look at any
catalytic cycle,
there'll be usually one step
that's really bad news,
until you get it fixed.
And that step is where it
controls the rate.
If you get steady state,
the slowest step -- this is a
real democracy,
catalysis.
There's no step that's more
important than any other.
The catalyst goes from each
step.
The titanium is moving through
those cycles.
If there's a slow step,
there's 99.9% of the titaniums
that you need,
stuck before this one mountain,
that goes way up like Mount
Everest.
You got to drop that one down.
If you get that one down,
the rate goes way up.
And if you get them all the
same height, you're really
rolling.
And that's a sacred rule.
The turnover-limiting step is
everything, in catalysis.
And a lot of times the
turnover-ruling step is so high,
they don't even know there is
catalysis.
If you can break that,
you'll find a world of
catalysis that didn't exist
before.
So that's what I think is
exciting about catalysis;
it's alive.
As long as you have some energy
to dissipate you're -- it's life
itself.
Then I'll finish this quickly
off, without any details.
You can see what I'm going to
do here.
It's just that that hot oxygen
atom, that's activated to
transfer.
This is the handle that would
be the allylic alcohol.
And so it's a dead ringer for
the Katsuki -- for the Bert
Rowland Patent,
right?
That's what I think.
And the amine,
yeah, the amine makes sense
here too.
And I guess that's --
Prof: So did that patent
apply to this process?
Prof: Well Stanford made
a little --
they brought over ten people,
from research,
and they brought over three
lawyers from AstraZeneca;
because Stanford thought maybe
they should get something out of
this.
And I told the story like this,
and they didn't -- they
pretended it didn't make any
sense at all.
You know?
And it was pretty unsatisfying.
Bert Rowland was there.
I don't know if he's still
alive.
He had cancer then.
But so we didn't -- but they'd
already made six billion
dollars;
because the catalyst patent was
the only extant patent.
But it did have this feature in
it.
And so they were right in the
-- I think they're right in the
face of the patent.
But they didn't like that.
And we didn't -- Stanford
wasn't going to pursue it.
Another thing we -- I'd like to
mention -- is they invited me
over.
This is before this meeting
about the patent.
I guess I started to notice the
old titanium chemistry,
and Katsuki and I talked,
and we agreed that maybe we
should raise our hand.
But before that,
what happened was I got invited
to go to a hotel in Munich,
the fanciest hotel,
and they put me in this big
room upstairs.
They wanted me to say something
about right- and left-handed
medicines.
And I had a little 15-minute
spot -- 1000 or 1200
gastroenterologists,
from Germany alone.
And they were doing a story
about how important drugs have
to be optically pure.
And that story doesn't wash too
well here.
And I didn't realize it,
when it was going.
But I went and I did my part.
And it is true that many drugs
are toxic in one form and good
in the other.
And I was able to make those
points.
But what happens here is -- oh,
and also they gave me this
suite on the top,
that had like a spiral
staircase to the bed,
at the very top;
and Madonna had stayed there
the week before.
>
That's okay for her.
She doesn't have a prostate
problem.
>
I hated that place.
I had to go -- they should've
had a fire pole so I could get
down to the bathroom.
Anyway.
What happens is,
as Mike told you,
you just look at the facts in
that system.
And I noticed them just the day
I was sitting there in the
audience, and the press was
interviewing us.
And I whispered to the guy next
to me, and he looked at me and
frowned.
It was about the weights.
All right?
I mean, the racemate 20 mgs,
and optically pure.
And I think the optically pure
is substantially more reactive,
in this case,
because it gets in better.
It's, of course,
just a pro-drug,
for the thing.
But the thing that was missing
from the experiments is the
forty milligrams of racemate,
which would give them
equivalence against the one
enantiomer of the twenty
milligrams of pure.
And that was missing,
and they doubled the -- and it
was just a sore thumb there for
me.
But I didn't say anything;
nobody asked me, fortunately.
Because if they had,
I would've said something about
it, I imagine.
It's the way we are.
Right, Mike?
Mike doesn't -- he smiles,
but he gets the hard evidence.
In the middle of your talk
sometimes he does this.
But for me it's the best thing
you can get.
Prof:
>
Prof: If you can get
killed by a friend,
it's the best way to get
killed.
>
Prof: Anyway,
I'm finished.
That's it.
Prof: Great.
>
Thanks again.
Prof: Yeah,
you're welcome.
Prof: We maybe have time
for one question or so,
before we get back to our
normal business.
Anybody got a question for
Professor Sharpless?
No. Well thanks again.
Prof: You're welcome.
Prof: Have a good trip
back.
<<Informal discussion
between Professor McBride and
Professor Sharpless>>
Prof: Okay thanks.
So long.
Good luck.
*
Prof: Okay,
back to our routine now.
<<Informal discussion
between Professor McBride and
Professor Sharpless>>
Prof: Oh,
he forgot to show this picture.
There he is with the royalty of
Sweden, and his wife,
and the other Nobel Laureates
in Chemistry.
Okay, and he was going to talk
about carvone too.
He wanted you to smell it.
I told him you'd smelled it.
But he had an idea for a novel
based on carvone,
which he didn't have time to
get to.
Okay, so we were talking about
the conformation of rings.
And we talked last time a lot
about cyclohexane,
and how it distorted --
remember, that it's not really
ideal,
with the axial bonds parallel
to the axis.
They spread out a little bit.
The ring flattens a little bit
to minimize the energy,
as calculated by molecular
mechanics.
Now how about in a
four-membered ring,
instead of a six-membered ring?
Well if we look at the,
what molecular mechanics says
about the source of strain in
this system,
you can see that the big
contributors are bend --
that's what Baeyer had already
talked about,
about the ring strain;
having 90°
angles is not going to be good;
so that's costing 13.5 kcal/mol
-- and torsion.
Because why is there such high
torsional energy;
15 kcal/mol, almost?
What's the source of that?
Anybody see?
As you go around the ring,
everything is exactly eclipsed.
Everybody see that?
Every carbon-carbon bond is
eclipsed.
Right?
So that, in molecular
mechanics, sums up to almost 15
kcal/mol.
Now, if you were -- how would
you try to minimize the energy?
Is this probably the lowest
energy form, or can you think of
changing it, so that it'll be
lower?
Any ideas? Kevin?
Student:  Make it so the
bond, in cyclobutane,
aren't exactly parallel to the
new bond.
Prof: Yeah,
if you make it not exactly
eclipsed,
if you make it a little bit
towards scatter- towards
staggered,
by twisting about the bonds,
that'll lower that 15 kcal/mol.
But, can you see what happens,
if you begin to twist around
the bonds?
It sharpens the angles even
more, from 90°
to smaller than 90°.
So here's what happens when you
do it.
The bending energy goes up,
by 2.5 kilocalories per mole.
Right?
But the torsional energy goes
down, by 3.5 kilocalories per
mole -- right?
-- if you don't bend it too far.
Okay, and the other things stay
pretty much the same.
So this is a competition
between torsion energy and
bending energy,
and the minimum is reached with
a little bit of bending,
in order to relieve some of
that torsion.
Now how about if you had a
five-membered ring?
Now you notice you have --
notice the bending energy isn't
bad,
because as Baeyer pointed out,
a pentagon,
a regular pentagon,
has just the right angles --
109.5° about.
Right?
So there's hardly any bending.
But there's still a lot of
torsion, from the eclipsing of
the carbons.
So what you do,
if you run the molecular
mechanics program,
is to cause bending energy to
occur;
that is, sharpen the angles a
little bit, right?
But you get rid of a lot of
torsional energy by doing that.
And this particular
conformation -- which you can
see how it's bent down;
the black carbon,
eight there -- is sometimes
referred to as the envelope
conformation of cyclopentane.
See how it looks like the fold
of the envelope bent down?
Okay, so there again is a
competition between bending and
torsion.
Now, like plastic models,
molecular mechanics is
satisfying because it says not
only what the structure should
be, but why.
What is it that makes the
energy the way it is?
Okay, so you remember last time
we passed around the
cyclohexanes.
Remember how they clicked,
to go from one form to another?
So what's happening?
The question is,
what's the source of the
barrier to the cyclohexane ring
flip?
So here's the chair
cyclohexane, and when the ring
starts to flip --
remember first you go toward a
boat,
by bending one of those carbons
up,
like that.
Now what do you think the
source of the energy is,
that makes this hard to do?
Why do you go to a maximum
energy, as you do this,
and then it clicks and it goes
down again?
Sherwin?
Student:  Torsion.
Prof: Torsion.
Now, that's a good point.
There are, in fact,
two bonds, two butanes,
that become eclipsed.
Right?
Both of the ones on the right.
This one is eclipsed,
but also this one is eclipsed;
those four.
Right?
And indeed, that's worth about
7 kcal/mol of going uphill.
But there's an interesting
point.
You did this with the models --
right?
-- and you felt it click.
How do those models,
those plastic models,
know from torsional energy?
Do you see what I mean?
If you take ethane in those
models, and spin it,
it spins completely freely.
There's nothing in the model.
You could make it -- you could
make the thing that goes into
the tube,
and the tube,
a little bit triangular,
so that as you tried to twist,
it would go up in energy and
then down again.
Right?
Do you see how you could do
that in a model?
But that's not the way those
are made.
They're cylinders,
they rotate freely.
So why did the model click?
Pardon me?
Student:  Bending.
Prof: Bending?
Of what?
Student:  The bonds.
Prof: Right,
exactly.
Look at this.
Why does the plastic model
click?
Because when you're halfway
across,
it's becoming -- if it were
flat, if the whole ring were
flat,
what would the
carbon-carbon-carbon angles be,
if the ring were flat?
Sam?
Student:  I don't know.
Prof: In a regular
hexagon, what's the angle?
Dana?
You got to be careful holding
your hand up,
even if it's just to scratch
your face.
What's the angle in a regular
hexagon?
Students:  120.
Prof: 120°.
It wants to be 109.
So it has to stretch out,
if it becomes flat.
And even when it becomes only
partly flat -- right?
-- this part of it is flat;
this one's out of the plane.
But that means in order to have
this one in there,
this bond gets compressed.
Right?
Because if these angles want to
be 109, instead of 120,
everything -- these are going
to move;
this one and this one will move
closer together.
So these are -- in this form,
when it's half planar,
these angles are bent out,
and that angle is bent in.
So it's the angle bending which
in fact does it,
does stress those plastic
models, which causes it to
click.
So it's interesting to be able
to look at models,
or at these calculations of
molecules as springs,
and see why various things
occur.
So are molecular mechanics
programs useful?
Yes, definitely they're useful.
Are they true?
No.
Okay, so we'll go on from there
next time.